لعلق رؤساء الكتل السياسيه في البرلمان
الاوروبي علقوا الاتصالات مع المسؤولين
الايرانيين
واكدت المتحدثه باسم البرلمان ان القراره
جاء ردا على ادراج السلطات الايرانيه عدد
من النواب الاوروبيين في قوائم العقوبات
الايرانيه
واضافت ان البرلمان سيناقش في اجتماعنا
الاسبوع المقبل في ستراسبورغ الرده على
حمله القمع ضد الاحتجاجات السلميه
في غضون ذلك شيعه اهالي مدينه تبريز طالبه
الطب الى حقه التي قتلت برصاص قوات الامن
اثناء الاحتجاجات بحسب قناه ايران
انترناشونال
وافادت القناه بان القوات الامن هاجمت
المشاركين في مراسم تشييع الجنازه حيث
فرضوا اجراءات امنيه مشدده
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك اشعل المتظاهرون حريقا في منزل
اجداد الخميني والذي تحول الى متحف
اللاحقان ببلده خمين بايران واظهرت الصور
اندلاعا النيران في المنزل الواقع في
محافظه مركزي في وقت تتصاعد في الاحتجاجات
التي تدخل شهرها الثالث
كنافه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سيارات